thanks for tuning into budget chef on
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie today we're
going to prepare a balanced budget by
the year 2020 and for a special treat
we're gonna do this without raising
taxes now at first it seems like a
really complicated dish but in fact it's
so incredibly simple that virtually any
elected official should be able to pull
it off all you have to do is spend no
more than you're taking in this big
piece of pork here represents the
combined budgets for the next 10 years
in order to balance the budget in 2020
what we need to do is to find a total of
1.3 trillion dollars in cuts or about a
hundred and thirty billion dollars a
year in each of the next ten years that
sounds like a lot until you realize you
only need to trim 3.6 percent of each
year's budget so here's the budget for
2011 to get started on the balanced
budget all we need to do is to cut this
little piece of fat right here now let's
work on the next nine budgets you know
with this dish you'll wow your trading
partners and foreign and domestic
investors and by making small systemic
cuts in the fatty parts of the budget
over the next decade we'll compounder
our savings and here's 2020s budget
which is projected to come in at about
five trillion dollars but because we
trimmed all this fat this is looking
pretty edible it wasn't so hard was it
if you want the full recipe for how to
balance the budget without raising taxes
you'll find it online at reason.com now
let's roast this baby Bon Appetit